[Música]
aquí inicia un nuevo capítulo de áfrica
siete días un magazine informativo 100%
dedicado al continente africano mi
nombre es andrés meza muñoz y estoy aquí
en reemplazo de mi compañera liliana
valencia a continuación nuestros
titulares
multitudinarias protestas en túnez en
contra del presidente karzai & miles de
personas salieron a las calles para
rechazar la adopción de medidas
excepcionales por parte del mandatario
que le permiten gobernar por decreto y
que han sido calificadas como un golpe
de estado crece la alerta en mali ante
la posible llegada de mercenarios rusos
del grupo warner el primer ministro
valiente dijo sentirse abandonado por la
decisión de francia de reducir sus
tropas en el país africano y por ello
dijo estar buscando otra ayuda militar
para poder combatir el terrorismo
en uganda las escuelas permanecen
cerradas ante el temor de un nuevo
aumento en los casos de kobe 19 mientras
que las familias más adineradas acceden
a clases en línea quienes no tienen
acceso a esta modalidad están
preocupados por el futuro de sus hijos
ya que no hay claridad sobre cuándo
reabrirán los centros educativos
empezamos en túnez donde unas 2000
personas salieron a las calles el pasado
26 de septiembre para protestar contra
las medidas del presidente de caixa jet
y para pedirle que renuncie esta fue la
mayor muestra de inconformismo público
desde que despidió a su primer ministro
y suspendió al parlamento en julio
una marea de colores rojo y blanco se
concentró en la capital tunecina era una
protesta contra lo que ellos llaman un
golpe de estado fue la mayor
manifestación de este tipo desde que el
presidente que isaías despidió a su
primer ministro suspendió el parlamento
y se otorgó poderes judiciales el 25 de
julio la semana pasada endureció ese
control al dejar de lado gran parte de
la constitución dándose a sí mismo el
poder de gobernar por decreto soy una de
las personas que se unieron a la campaña
de caixa jet incluso soy una de sus
antiguos alumnos pero no puedo tolerar
lo que está sucediendo ahora él ha
perdido mi confianza
que restituya la constitución para que
votemos libremente no nos gustó lo que
pasó en julio que nos den la libertad de
votar como todos los países democráticos
la protesta tuvo lugar bajo una fuerte
presencia de seguridad una serie de
barricadas se instalaron para controlar
el acceso a determinadas zonas también
se desplegaron furgonetas policiales y
vehículos blindados hicimos una
revolución para tener algo nuevo para
que la gente pudiera expresarse a través
de órganos como el parlament y no tener
a alguien que decida tomar todos los
poderes para sí mismo y que habla en
nombre del pueblo el presidente está jet
afirma que su intervención fue necesaria
para abordar el estancamiento político
en túnez así como la crisis económica y
el mal manejo de la pandemia el
mandatario todavía tiene un amplio apoyo
entre muchos tunecinos que están
cansados de la corrupción pero la
oposición a su gobierno está creciendo
decenas de grupos de derechos humanos
nacionales e internacionales emitieron
una declaración para condenar lo que
describieron como la toma de poder de
sawyer calificándola como el primer paso
hacia el autoritarismo
el primer ministro de male dijo sentirse
abandonado por francia ante la decisión
del país galo de reducir sus tropas en
la nación africana durante la asamblea
general de la onu sowell maygar señaló
que está buscando otra ayuda militar
para combatir el terrorismo lo que
alimenta los rumores sobre la eventual
presencia del grupo warner en la nación
africana esta organización es señalada
de llevar a cabo ejecuciones
extrajudiciales violaciones y torturas
durante sus misiones
siguen los rumores sobre la posible
presencia de mercenarios rusos del grupo
warner en mali el ministro de exteriores
de rusia serguéi lávrov confirmó que
bamako solicitó una empresa privada
militar de su país sus servicios en la
lucha contra el terrorismo pero descartó
que el kremlin estuviera vinculado
no tenemos nada que ver con esto esta es
una actividad que se lleva a cabo sobre
una base legal legítima y se aplica a
las relaciones entre el estado anfitrión
el gobierno legítimo del estado
anfitrión que es reconocido por todos
como una estructura de transición
legítima por un lado y aquellos que
prestan el servicio a través de
especialistas extranjeros
el primer ministro de mahle dijo ante la
asamblea general de la onu que su país
estaba buscando otra ayuda militar ante
la decisión de francia de reducir sus
tropas de la nación africana el
mandatario dijo sentirse abandonado y en
una entrevista en france 24 no descartó
que se tratara del grupo warner
no conozco al grupo warner son los
medios los que hablan de ello no se digo
que el objetivo del gobierno de malí es
firmar un acuerdo que dure mucho tiempo
lo haremos público con quien firmamos la
posible llegada de wágner a mali
mantienen alerta occidente pues se
señalada de llevar a cabo ejecuciones
extrajudiciales violaciones y torturas
durante sus misiones el jefe de la
diplomacia europea dijo que esto podría
afectar la relación del país africano
con la unión
para militares rusos los instructores de
seguridad privada y las empresas se han
vuelto cada vez más influyentes en
áfrica en los últimos años
particularmente en zonas asoladas por el
conflicto rusia niega vínculos con
warner pero varias pruebas entre ellas
testimonios de los propios mercenarios
demuestran lo contrario
pasamos a nigeria al menos 34 personas
murieron en la ciudad de madama y en el
estado de kaduna al noroeste del país
tras ser atacadas por hombres armados
otras siete personas resultaron heridas
tras el ataque de acuerdo con las
autoridades las fuerzas armadas se
desplazaron al lugar e intercambiaron
disparos con los autores del siniestro
quienes también incendiaron algunas
casas varios estados del noroeste del
país sufren constantes ataques por parte
de grupos criminales implicados en el
robo de ganado y secuestro para
conseguir dinero por el rescate pasamos
ahora a sudáfrica a bordo de un tren un
grupo de trabajadores de la salud busca
llegar a las zonas más remotas del país
para aplicar la vacuna contra el kobe 19
el proyecto pretende combatir los
obstáculos que han dificultado la
campaña de inmunización entre ellos la
desinformación sobre el fármaco y la
falta para su aplicación
una forma más de combatir el kobe 19 en
sudáfrica a bordo de un tren un grupo de
trabajadores llega hasta las zonas más
remotas para persuadir a las personas de
aplicarse la vacuna contra el virus
jameson la misión del tren es ayudar el
gobierno vacunar a tantas personas como
sea posible en el corto tiempo exceso
además de la desinformación que se
propaga en contra las vacunas la falta
de instalaciones para la aplicación del
fármaco es otro de los principales
obstáculos para completar el programa de
inmunización en esta zona pero la
campaña de vacunación no se limita al
vagón del tren en cada estación el grupo
está encargado de recorrer los
alrededores para aumentar el número de
inmunizados llegando incluso hasta
fábricas y compañías aledañas un gran
número de residentes de la ciudad de su
arco celebra esta iniciativa estoy
realmente en paz con el hecho de que ya
no existe he estado esperando el momento
en el que puedo decir que estoy entre
los vacunados en sudáfrica
todavía quedan varias ciudades por
visitar y el personal de salud espera
que la iniciativa les permita ayudar a
que sudáfrica pueda volver a la
normalidad lo antes posible
uganda es el único país de áfrica
oriental que no ha reabierto las
escuelas primarias desde el inicio de la
pandemia de kobe 19 en marzo de 2020
durante estos 18 meses de cierre solo
las familias más ricas pudieron
inscribir a sus hijos en clases en línea
pero la mayoría de los grandes no tienen
acceso a esta modalidad dado que las
autoridades temen un nuevo aumento en
los casos de kobe 19 aún no está claro
si las escuelas volverán a abrir pronto
el gobierno está bajo presión ya que
algunos expertos advierten sobre las
consecuencias negativas para los más de
15 millones de alumnos que no han ido a
clases durante un año y medio
desde el comienzo de la pandemia kabira
de 16 años sólo ha ido la escuela unas
pocas semanas ha perdido casi dos años
académicos su madre está tratando de
educar la en casa para ayudarla a
ponerse al día
hablemos de biología
organismos sabes algo de organismos
la madre de cabina tiene que comprar
libros escolares a los vendedores
ambulantes a ambas les resulta difícil
mantenerse al tanto de los temas claves
como la que estás en casa sin hacer nada
y si uno quiere seguir leyendo solo
durante un nuevo nivel necesita una
explicación del profesor
petronila está preocupada por el futuro
de sus hijos
ella ha perdido las ganas de estudiar
incluso los más jóvenes ven a la gente
sentada mi miedo es que hasta puedan
adoptar otros hábitos que antes no
existían
después de 18 meses sin trabajo a los
profesores también les resulta difícil
me dijeron que a los maestros se les
retrasó el pago de sus salarios durante
los últimos meses es eso cierto
y estamos perdiendo mano de obra vamos a
perder profesores experimentados vamos a
perder buenos profesores
pero las autoridades dicen que la
prioridad es prevenir una nueva ola de
contagios de bisturí todavía existe la
necesidad de tener las escuelas cerradas
pero cuando se abran no permitiremos que
todos los alumnos vuelvan a la escuela
eso es lo que estamos pidiendo una
apertura de manera escalonada en la que
algunas clases vuelvan clases go back to
school hasta el momento no se ha fijado
una fecha para la reapertura de escuelas
las autoridades esperan que vacunar a
los profesores sea parte de la solución
y finalizamos en libia con la historia
de una joya cultural de la que muy pocos
se habla una vez entre las ciudades más
bellas del imperio romano leptis magna
ha sido descuidada e ignorada por los
turistas durante décadas en medio del
caos que ha asolado al país ahora una
pausa tras un año de la violencia ha
generado esperanzas de que libia pueda
seguir adelante y algunos ven el
potencial para el renacimiento de leptis
magna
durante más de 2000 años sobrevivió a
sucesivas oleadas de conquistadores una
vez una de las ciudades más bellas del
imperio romano leptis magna también se
ha librado en su mayoría de la violencia
que ha azotado a libia desde la revuelta
de 2011 pero ahora se enfrenta a otra
amenaza la negligencia
está la falta de suministros que nunca
existió en primer lugar el hecho de que
se han interrumpido las excavaciones
arqueológicas los medios y el apoyo del
gobierno que son prácticamente
inexistentes
fundada en el siglo séptimo antes de
cristo- por marineros fenicios y luego
conquistada por romà leptis magna fue el
lugar de nacimiento de septimio severo
quien se convirtió en emperador sus
ruinas bien conservadas incluyen una
gran basílica un hipódromo y un
anfiteatro con vistas al mediterráneo
tiene potencial turístico y sin embargo
apenas hay un visitante el turismo es
escaso en libia estamos preparados para
ello por ejemplo el tren de la ciudad
debe recibir mantenimiento para el
transporte de turistas los pasillos
deben estar pavimentadas necesitamos más
iluminación y aire acondicionado en el
verano después de 10 años de conflicto y
colapso estatal el actual gobierno de
unidad de libia tiene otras prioridades
pero los cuidadores de leptis magna
esperan que el alto el fuego de octubre
de 2020 se mantenga y que el sitio
finalmente atraiga la atención que se
merece
hasta aquí áfrica 7 días este y otros
episodios del programa lo pueden
encontrar en nuestra página web www
puntos 24 punto com y recuerden que
ahora france24 emite en español durante
las 24 horas del día quédense con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]